[Music]
right here in Franklin Tennessee we are
so glad that you decided to join us
tonight to talk about a very important
topic the student loan debt crisis and
more importantly how to go to college
debt-free tonight you're gonna hear real
stories of real people who did just that
they went to college debt-free and
you're also gonna hear from experts and
get your college questions answered it's
gonna be a great great time if you
didn't know the student loan debt crisis
is crippling America we've got 44
million Americans walking around with
1.6 trillion dollars in student loan
debt that is not ok but we're not here
just to talk about the problem we want
to offer up a solution one that actually
works one that could change the economy
change your lives change the lives of
generations to come
you see like many of you I fell for a
lot of myths and lies when it came to
college I worked hard in high school and
then I went to the college that I wanted
to go to and I ended up graduating with
$25,000 in student loan debt and after
graduation those payments came due and I
felt the crushing weight of student loan
debt and I stand here today happy to
tell you that those debts are long gone
but for millions of Americans the
pressure of college and the weight of
student loan debt is so so real so what
are we gonna do about it we're gonna
have a debt-free degree Town Hall and
we've got some good news for you there
is hope there's hope for you and there
is hope for those millions of Americans
out there in future future generations
to come so here's what we're gonna do we
are going to offer up a solution and who
better than some financial experts we've
got two best-selling authors here
tonight
Anthony O'Neil and Dave Ramsey would you
guys please help me welcome them to the
stage
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
Wow I'm old I've been doing this talk
radio show of mine for almost 30 years
and I've been taking calls from the very
first week I was on the air until just a
few minutes ago from people with student
loan debt student loan debt that has
owned a decade or two of their lives
student loan debt that has hampered
their dreams and has held them back it's
out of control
there's an epic pandemic plague in
America and we did it to ourselves and
we allowed Congress to do it to us and
we allowed predatory lenders to do it to
us and one person on our team Remzi
personality best-selling author has
spoken to more high-school students and
has a big heart for high school students
and students all across America is best
selling off their Anthony O'Neal and he
is just the man for this hour to take on
this subject and I'm so proud of you
so proud of you thank you for doing all
your doing and this whole debt-free
degree movement way to go man thank you
so much Dave thank you so much yeah
you know Dave you know America I've had
the opportunity to travel around the
world and speak to nearly millions of
young people and as I'm going into high
school is as I'm talking to parents
parents are frustrated they're scared
they're nervous young people like what
do I do next and the number one thing is
they're asking me how do I go to college
it's I just need to take out student
loans I'm gonna go to my dream school
and they're scared they're in fear
because they believe taking out student
loans is the only way that they can go
to college and it just gets me so upset
that the culture has put this onto our
young people and it's setting them up to
fail not to succeed and so what we're
doing tonight I'm excited because we're
gonna bring the solutions to answers to
a false lot that they're getting you
know that's important to talk about
because you know if you tell something
loud enough long enough and often enough
yeah even if it's not the truth
eventually people begin to believe it
yeah if there's no other kid dissenting
voices if no one's out there going hey
that's stupid you know if nobody's
calling you on your stupid and the
culture just continues to continues to
grow it over and over and over to where
high school guidance counselor's believe
the only way to go to schools Deb it is
it's student loan debt student believes
the only way to go to school student
loan debt the media believes the only
way to go to schools student loan debt
and you get to where you're thinking
it's like this is only go to school
because everybody believes this stupid
lie and when you start doing the math it
is a lie but to the point that you and I
put on social media you know it's
possible to go to that free and you know
what we tell people that there's hope
and you can go to school debt-free and
you know what we get hate-hate rollers
yes crazy people on Twitter and I love
them thank you so much but you know what
no Dave and I think that's where we have
to really step back that's why we're
here we're bringing hope I remember my
father had a GI Bill and I was able to
go to school without taking out any
student loans but I still took out
student loans because of all the lies
that was told to me its norm it's okay
take a mountain fund John there I like
about those stories oh I love the story
when you put a stereo tell us Dave
Dave we're here to help American that's
alright people my story dumbest thing
I've ever heard
this is so great what you did tell me
what you did
so I mean my very first credit card my
mom was here and she got on my nerves
about this credit card to say you do not
need it so the very first credit card I
put five hundred dollars just on a lady
that spent $150 at Red Lobster
oh yeah really not bad day back in the
days then ready the Builder was was hey
miss but a Red Lobster $150 $150 on some
roses I mean $200 on a purse so I paid
it and where Dave is talking about when
I got to increase I was driving a 1987
Nissan Maxima and I wouldn't put a $500
sound system in the back of the car and
the car couldn't even go in reverse
and we all doing something about like
that this is this is where your student
loan debts going yeah this is the kind
of stuff people spend their student loan
money on that's why I bring it up not
just pick on you it's a great story are
you funny right it's all good I just
love making fun with you but but I mean
this is the kind of crap you do when you
give a 17 or an 18 year old with
absolutely no guidance and no boundaries
whatsoever unlimited cash flow and no
controls on it they go do stupid stuff
man when I was 17 I didn't have two
brain cells to rub together you 17 year
olds are up there a lot smarter than me
I was dumber than a rock man number than
a grub worm in a box of rocks and you
didn't need to be giving me unfettered
money because it was going to go stupid
stuff like into us into a car that the
stereos worth more than the car yeah
yeah yeah but here's the thing Dave
you're right and here's the thing
America we are allowing our students to
take a kids approach to an adult
decision boom you hear that one do it
again alright we are allowing our kids
to take a kid's approach to an adult
decision they're not thinking about
their future was I wasn't thinking about
my 40 year old my 50 year old self I was
thinking about oppressing the ladies at
18 had the sweetest little girl call me
on the radio the other day from South
Carolina okay and you know she said what
she said I said I want to go to Ole Miss
Ole Miss and I said well that's good do
you have the money no I'm taking out
student loans I guess and I said well
why are you going to Ole Miss why are
you paying three times more to go across
the state line I mean South Carolina's a
good school Ole Miss is a good school
they're both good schools right why are
you paying three times more out-of-state
tuition to go to Ole Miss you know what
answer watched what was answer campus is
pretty okay it's a pretty town yeah a
beautiful town but that's all she's
gonna be $40,000 in debt cause the key
this is pretty and and her parents
aren't going not gonna log in on her
head man but you know it is our fault
it's our parents fault we're not
allowing we're not helping our young
people to make good decisions we're
saying hey go to do go to Harvard go to
yo you'll get this big old dream job
it's a beautiful campus when what
they're gonna really come out with is a
lot of debt now if they graduate if they
graduate and only 52 percent of people
to start college graduate and one
percent of people take out student loans
have student loans it's improving
statistical fact I mean you know we're
not against you going in where you want
to go to school why don't you pay for it
yeah I'm with you and don't justify and
rationalize it based on stupid stuff
because you don't want be stupid about
education it's gonna auction moronic
yeah you know and we just the culture
has done that we've lost our ever-loving
freakin minds man we really have it's
crazy and we're not the only ones I
think this no no we're we're not and to
even set up tonight I'm just excited to
really dive deeper into this whole
subject and we're gonna bring up one of
our good friends dr. John dill only I
call him short for dr. D cuz the
students call him dr. D but he has a PhD
in education in higher education and
this man knows exactly what we're
talking about he's seeing it firsthand
and we asked him to come he's good
friend of Dave's good friend of Mines
his good friend of our organization and
so can y'all help me welcome to the
stage dr. John dill only please
[Applause]
take it
sit in the middle swing gang up on you
yeah we need all of your all of your all
of your information so I mean I'm doing
well I'm so good you look good are you
married I'm married
pray for me uh well he ain't got holes
in the knees of the jeans that's right
you're struggling struggling financially
Oh
everybody needs to buy a book this
evening go but now wait a minute if I'm
struggling financially I work for David
no no but all Sears know the money is no
issue I work for Dave anyway
hey man as a as an expert in this
particular field we are attacking this
through the loan crisis what are you
seeing right now in your particular
field on your campus with young people
that's coming onto your campus um I
think it's extends beyond my campus if
any I think it's something that I dealt
with 20 years ago when I was in school
all the way through now to where we've
got students who are taking on
increasingly amount of creasing amounts
of debt they are not sleeping at night I
remember pacing around my house not
sleeping tonight wondering I was gonna
pay this off we've got students with
increased anxiety increased depression
there they're picking jobs that they
have no interest in Wow and particularly
concerned for me I've got two little
kids I want there to be great teachers
and great ministers and great public
service attorneys and those are jobs
that they can't take sometimes because
they are forced to take other other jobs
are gonna be better ROI right yeah so
for people watching right now what
school are you at right now what
university you can do that to me on
national T I'm Scott Belmont University
I hear naturally to the Dean of Students
at Belmont yes there you go all right so
you're meeting with these kids as a Dean
of Students and you're hearing and and
you're actually experiencing their
emotional state as they're going into
this debt as this is piling up they
start to see it before they get out
don't they and so what are you telling
them it's it's it's make good decisions
it is to really believe to ask
themselves is just a place that they
need to be where does the school that is
gonna get them where they want to go
when they want to get there and what
they were
- and I think so many students don't
have that conversation before they go
I'm blessed to be at a university where
it's it's it's rather niche University
so students have thought through that
but over the last 15 years working with
colleges and university students just
show up and then they expect it all to
magically pay for itself and the jobs
just to be there that's just not the
world we live in so what are you telling
them regarding this whole message of you
mean in your experience you've got a PhD
in higher ed you're sitting in the seat
at a major university or the dean of
students is it really possible to go to
school debt-free to see it all the time
you see it all the parents I mean how
you do it that helps I think we have
students who pretend that college isn't
gonna happen until they get to be 18
years old and then they start to decide
well we should probably figure this out
and moms and dads when you have children
that's a conversation you should start
having the day they are born that's a
conversation my wife and I had when our
first son was born and then they don't
ask what's the value of this degree
where I'm going to school don't borrow
money on on on valueless paper write ask
yourself what do you really want to do
and why do you want to do it and where
do you want to do it and is there
actually a position in the real world
that pays you for doing that that's
exactly right
don't spend four hundred fifty thousand
dollars getting a degree in something
that makes you fifty thousand bucks a
year you've been dead the rest of your
life I'll make everybody a deal if you
pay me four hundred fifty thousand
dollars I'll give you fifty of it back
the next day so being a Dean at your
particular school how do you feel about
community colleges you know that the
world is saying if you go off to
Community College she didn't succeed in
high school that's a bad decision you
failed how do you feel about community
colleges and trade schools for example
my mom she entered higher education at
42 years old
took one Community College class and I
we either took geometry together or
algebra together I was a freshman in
high school the next year she took one
more class the next year she took one
more class she got an associate's degree
and one professor said keep going and
then she went down to the local City
College kept going she graduated their
PhD at age 57 and I won't tell you how
old she is now but she spent the summer
in Oxford in England
Ireland on like this extraordinary back
half of her life
the answer is yes I've hi hi like I hold
community colleges of high esteem yeah
students you can get your degree you can
get your degree absolutely
what's your college story man I went to
I signed a full scholarship in February
my senior year of high school didn't
think of it again I met a girl at church
camp and at a another school told my dad
I think I'm gonna marry that girl and
then I went out to a tiny unranked and
small school in the middle of nowhere
Texas and we broke up two or three days
into school and I was there gave up and
then she dumped you that's right that's
not I don't that's right and and then I
graduated there and then I went down the
street to a local City College and got a
master's degree and then got a PhD and
then a couple years later I went back
and got a second PhD in counseling and
so and then I figured out how to get the
people that you work for to help pay for
it so I like to say is I went to a
school that's not any of the magazines
that have lovely professors had
extraordinary faculty great people who
poured into my life and I'm getting I'm
sitting on a stage with Dave Ramsey and
Anthony O'Neil right now write your PhD
right and I get to work at a university
like Belmont which is just second to
none so I've had to not by not playing
the game and really working hard diving
into your college experience planning
ahead of time it's been a really
remarkable story as I'm in high schools
the number one thing I'm not number one
but one of the top things I'm always
asked by high school students is I can't
go to my dream school like Belmont I
can't go to Harvard I got to go over
here but I'm willing to take out student
loans to do this and take on this debt
for this what do you say to young people
watching this right now and everyone in
this room that's a you know if my dream
is to go here but they really can't
afford it are they missing out by not
going my dream car is some form of
tundra or a Lexus and I drove a Corolla
for like 18 years man you know that car
dear that got me from here to there my
wife still loved me
she was with me forever and so what I
tell young people all the time is we all
have dreams and sometimes what you don't
get ends up being the greatest blessing
in your life right
now that it dream done wrong turns into
a nightmare that's really comes into and
when you try to take some things we've
designed to be a blessing and you do it
in an improper way provided for with
improper processes the blessing leaves
and it looks severely like a curse
that's right I want students to know
that they drive this process come on
they drive the process they are the ones
who are able to say word I want to go
what I'm going to do and there's this
flood of marketing information that if
you don't do this if you don't do that
like you said guidance counselor's
friends parents students understand your
and control this process and getting
through on the other end with the degree
forget the degree the training that's
gonna help you be a better person the
trains can help you get the job that you
need and take care of that family that
you want to start if that's what we're
looking for on the back end of this now
and the thing you say when they're
driving the process that you know I was
talking about the young lady not
choosing South Carolina before you came
on stage and show it was trying to
choose Ole Miss but you're very
comparative school something just
ridiculous in the two academically
speaking it's just across the state line
that's all it is you just across the
state line you've got no value
whatsoever you just crossed an invisible
line that some guy drew five you know
three hundred years ago two hundred
years ago you went across a line and you
tripled your cost and then it just
drives me nuts so they control the
decisions with their intention ality out
of a hundred students that you're seeing
what percentage would you say are
intentional where they set the whole
thing up that would as Stephen Covey
used to say begin with the end in mind
say this is my goal and here's what its
gonna cost me all along and here's what
the funding looks like how many of them
start with that kind of intentionality I
know when I went school I didn't I just
went ah beer pong you know and so you
know we just went off Infini were a
Bible class some would say yeah yeah I
applied
I was at a different Bible class um I
think the last two universities I've
worked at we're set up in a way that
students were highly intentional on the
front end and I think that's been a
blessing my work with college students
across the board has been not very many
and I think that conversation should
start in schools I should start in homes
and really hopefully messages like this
will put that I call them financial aid
free agents I learned that from a buddy
who's an enrollment management person
financial aid free agents you're the
ones who are gonna have to live with
this you're the one that's gonna have to
make sure that you get the value and
then you're gonna be the one that when
you walk across that stage you know that
degree you're staring at the rest of
your world you know the thing I see the
most is students don't understand that
this is not invisible money Wow
someone's gonna have to pay this back
and that's you and so it feels like it's
free money there you go that's right
it's not Todd that's right that's just
like you know here we go baby that's
right yeah yeah that's exactly right now
so you and I were talking in another
conversation a few months back a few
weeks back and um let's zoom back from
the individual student and look at the
national problem from a second I mean
PhD in higher ed you're sitting in again
the students in a major university these
student loans funded by Congress really
stimulate the economy and you made a you
put a phrase in there as far as economic
stimulus not want you to bring that out
for a second
I think the the way the way I look at it
is a I can off-book stimulus package
it's a way to put money in the hands of
eighteen thirty five year-olds let them
have the opportunity to invest in
themselves some 18 year-olds do that
when I was 18 I was not that savvy
well they drive the restaurant business
in that town they drive the housing
business in that town that they drive
the auto business in that town they
drive the alcohol sales in that town
they drive the everything in that town
and it's all funded by federally insured
student loans and no one called it a
stimulus package
it's an off-the-books under-the-table
congress-led stimulus package I hadn't
thought about that way to you brought it
up
which makes me kind of Angry
because I you know that one more time
than fooling one on us or their Saddam
they don't know it and either reason
maybe we should be angry at them either
that dumb or that crooked I'm not sure
we it's out of control one more question
for you
for those watching us right now across
the world there may be a parent on there
thinking that how do I do this I'm
taking out student loans may be a young
person saying I want to go to school I
think I have to take out student loans I
think I have to do this what would you
give that person watching right now
what's that one piece of encouragement
you'll give them I would say to sit down
and find some true wisdom sit down with
somebody who cares about him who works
in this business somebody who has got
through on the other end debt-free and
really look at what they want to do and
where they want to go and start planning
as early as possible
this doesn't sneak up on anybody it's
it's like when when my wife was first
pregnant we knew a nine months ish we're
gonna have a kid right and we need to
have a it's like having a baby and then
going oh no where we gonna put it right
you have a nursery and you have a career
view all that stuff already and I see so
many students across the country who
graduate high school and then they think
I gotta come up with a lot of money in
the next three months right that's a
conversation to have way before then and
to begin to say what is the role
Community College plays in my future
family tree it changed my family tree
Anthony that's the community college
changed my family tree and a really
profound insight tuition what does the
role of living in my mother's basement
and driving to school in state two it's
right that's what I did in my first year
that's right what does that what does
that do it cuts your cost in half that's
right I said on scholarship committees
and we would have this same five
students apply for all these scholarship
just went unfunded these are internal
these are college people trying to give
away their own money and students
wouldn't apply form Wow
apply for scholarship life for all why
would you not why would you buy lottery
tickets and scratch that at least try to
get some scholarship money that makes
what no one else was in line for that's
right no it's um don't give up on
yourself before you even get started
that's good just good you guys can we
give it up for dr. Jill only
today somebody appreciate you man thank
you brother
dr. tool Oni all right let's get to some
questions we've got some from the
audience as well as social media thank
you for all of you submitting those and
I want to start with one right here in
our crowd come on up young lady now tell
us your name Claire Miller Claire and
where you're from
North Carolina all right thanks for
making the trip to Nashville and your
question for Dave and Anthony first of
all I just want to say what an honor
I am so my question how can I get
guaranteed scholarships and how can I
stand out from those who have already
applied to increase my chance of getting
them that's a good question in Maine a
what part of North Carolina from a
Columbus Columbus yeah I'm from
Fayetteville North Carolina so we rockin
together thank you for coming but here's
the very first thing is the best way to
get a guarantee scholarship is you have
to guarantee yourself and you're gonna
wake up every single day and go after it
you got to treat the scholarship search
like it is your job every single day I
suggest spending at least one hour to
two hours every day going after it then
I will also suggest go check out my
website Anthony oh com4 slash
scholarships on there I have a great
tool that will help you get scholarships
I'm gonna like about this tool is I'm
gonna give you the best quality
scholarships it's gonna ask you some
questions about yourself and when you
get that here's the secret I want you to
go after the small ones don't go after
the big ones because there's nearly a
billion scholarships going to waste all
the time every year and studies are
showing that nearly 50% of those are
five thousand and less so I want you to
go after the younger ones not younger
ones but the smaller ones 500 $1,000 and
$2,000 and what's going to make you
stand out it's just your hard work ethic
everyone else is just trying to get by
you just heard our professor and our
professionals say that you know we have
a lot of money left go after those and
treat it like it's your job the second
thing is Anthony's scholarship tool is
free by the way
doesn't cost a thing for you get on
there that's Patricia from North
Carolina try a bunch of different things
in the essays and things you're filling
out and if you if a certain way of
saying something or some certain thing
you're saying about yourself tends to
get you that scholarship for instance I
know a young lady that she kept putting
on there that she
had done missions trips and didn't do
any good but when she got real detailed
about who was being served in the
mission strips and she was gone on the
on the mission field in Haiti and
working with orphans and she really got
detailed and painted a picture of the
orphanage and the whole thing then all
of a sudden it came alive there was a
narrative to go with it and then look
for things that are uniquely different I
mean in my case I would look for
scholarships for bald guys white guys
from the south you know that have a bad
accent in your case if you've got an
ethnicity to your family utilize that
that may split off and do away with my
it may be designed for a minority of
some kind be looking for that and take
advantage of that because a lot of
scholarships these days are aimed at
particular areas trying to stimulate an
area of the country or an ethnicity
that's not been given doing higher
education I don't know what that is
interview case or even if it applies but
you don't have to don't make it up or
something don't lie about your your
background but but you know if there's
something there use that and your field
of study talk about what you're going to
do with the field of study to further
humanity that you're going to add value
to this culture you're a giver you're
not a taker and when you present that
kind of thing in these scholarships
things that sets you apart because most
of the scholarship applications and
essays are like please give me some free
money because I need some free money
please give me some free money you know
instead you talk about what you're
adding value instead of what you're
taking and it shifts it around for you
solid thank you thank you for coming
thank you Claire a great question all
right we're gonna move on to some
questions from social media this one
comes in from Facebook
Joanne asks my daughter graduates this
year and I don't know where to start
when it comes to paying for college help
well hey I want to first say this Joanna
that youth you are alright I remember
those days having a conversation with my
dad and I was saying hey what are we
gonna do how are we going to do this and
we were just wondering what are we gonna
do we started visiting things looking at
things so you're not by yourself but
here's the very first thing that I want
to encourage you is do not rush do not
allow these emotions to make you rush
into a decision that you will regret in
your future and in your child's future I
want you to step back and I want you to
have a plan and look at your financial
life I want to make sure that you are
okay fine
we know for sewer you are going to
retire your child may not finish college
and so make sure that you are well but
then after that I want you to look at
what do you how much do you have saved
can you put something in there
what is your child doing are they
looking up grants in scholarships every
single day and if you can't answer those
questions to the best we need to be
looking in to community colleges trade
schools and tech technical options so
that's why we recommend any time you're
making an overwhelming decision options
are power more options you have the
decision will rise to the top and be
right in front of you and so don't
narrow it down to like there's only
three schools on the planet - God won't
split you to go - oh boy
there's a bazillion schools and all of
them have degrees and all I'm gonna get
you through so the only thing is what's
it cost which is the primary issue yeah
we got to find something you can that's
why we keep going back to community
colleges because they're about one-tenth
the cost for the first two years in most
cases have some states they're free yes
sir right and so what's the cost and
that's when you start looking at in
state versus out-of-state and you go
well there's absolutely no value add and
it's a fourfold expense that's just
ludicrous unless you just got extra
money to just burn and in your case you
don't so we're going with something
that's a value based decision where can
we get the education at the best
purchase price yes you know when I was a
kid we used to go to Kmart jmo Kmart I
remember that my mom with the Kmart yeah
and when you go in there there'd be like
a blue light on
they had these blue light specials and
all the broke people like me would float
flock to the blue lights like moths to a
flame right and so that's what you're
looking for you're looking for a blue
light special that's it on education so
you're laying out okay here's what this
one cost you is what this one culture is
what this one cost is with this one cost
and you go okay just based on cost alone
I've got a spectrum here and that starts
to give me a picture of what I've got to
do if I live at home if I stay here well
that starts to change the cost because
if you got to go you know two hours away
you gotta you're gonna have to have
living expenses you just double it just
in yeah basically doubled in-state
tuition in-state tuition is about ten
thousand a year
takes about another ten thousand a year
to live on campus in most areas this may
be a little bit more yeah and so you
just double it just for living expenses
yeah now Dave you're talking about
pretty much doing a research
prime example if you live
North Carolina like the previous young
lady North Carolina just came out two or
three universities one of them is UNC
Pembroke if you get accepted into
Pembroke you're only paying $500 a
semester for a four-year school no I
don't know how they just came up with
the program but the thing is you do the
research don't want we don't care how I
really yeah and it's not a pop of the
school but look Kelly this dude in math
Dave that's a thousand dollars a year
that's a four thousand dollars for a
four-year degree I mean you can cash
flow that within one year actually hey
man you can you know just get you one of
them leaf blowers and walk around the
rich neighborhood rich people are afraid
elite oh they will pay you for them
you walk right through 500 bucks oh uh
so Dave I'll be at your house tomorrow
morning all right thank you all for
those great questions we're gonna be
doing more of that later on but for now
our team has been hard at work working
on all kinds of projects around the
student loan debt crisis and one that
we're so excited to announce today is
the release of borrowed future it's the
latest podcast from the Ramsey Network
and it's an 8 episode series exploring
the student loan debt crisis and the
impact that's having on real people
you're not just gonna hear from the
experts you're gonna hear from people
burdened by student loan debt and people
who have graduated college debt-free and
the great news is it's out today episode
1 just released our team put together an
amazing trailer to get America pumped
about this check it out as Americans we
enjoy more freedoms and opportunities
than any other nation on earth we have
the chance to get an education and give
our children a better life that is what
makes us different that is what sets us
apart that is what makes us Americans
congratulations on your graduation
[Applause]
forty-three million borrowers have about
one and a half trillion dollars in
student loan debt there's a whole lot of
people who view your ability to take on
debt as their chance to get rich they're
all part of a system to brainwash kids
into thinking this is normal this is
safe this is what you've been working
for we're having 19 euro signing for
what I was signed for a mortgage it
keeps young kids from beat entrepreneurs
than jobs that they don't like from
buying houses from investing in their
dreams every day I talked to someone
who's got a hundred thousand or two
hundred thousand or two hundred fifty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and they do not know what to do every
card I really just wanted to drive off
the cliff because those words more dead
than the law
if it's so bad that we need to forgive
the lungs why are we continuing to make
them Congress needs to stop the
federally insured student loan program
now now
this crisis is real and the deception is
everywhere or an offer a solution that
could change the economy and generations
to come
this generation is falling into bondage
because of the lack of knowledge our
conversation is not on to give you
knowledge but teach you how to avoid the
traps
I'm no longer gonna be slave to a system
it tells me I have to do it this way and
go and debt to do it this is your life
take control of it you're gonna walk
into your future not a part of the staff
of starting a new step you can create a
new norm this is gonna be a journey but
it's gonna be worth it
it can be done
absolutely incredible we are so excited
about it and like I said Episode one
just released go listen and subscribe
wherever you get your podcast share it
with a friend we want to spread the word
about the student loan debt crisis and
what we can do about it now next up for
our debt free degree Town Hall we wanted
to actually introduce you to some
students who did it
the unicorn's who graduated from college
debt-free we're gonna find out how they
did it we've got six of them on stage
right now along with Anthony O'Neill
let's hear it for them so as I'm
traveling around people are saying it's
impossible you got to have rich family
to do it you got to be wealthy yourself
or you just got to be extremely lucky to
go to school 100% debt-free and I said
that's focus and so got what Dave got
with our team and we all agree just to
go find some normal good looking sisters
and brothers are you saying no and so I
just really want y'all to introduce
yourself to say your name where you from
and just very quickly don't go into
details but how did you pay for school
we'll start right here with you
I'm Christina Ellis I am from Vincennes
Indiana and I won over a half a million
dollars in scholarships and was able to
attend my dream school Vanderbilt
University and go to grad school at
Belmont University completely debt-free
what
[Applause]
we don't come back and talk about his
half-million-dollar hope you to twist it
ain't good just slide over it that quick
but go hey you're next Laura Brown and I
live in Lexington Kentucky I go to the
University of Kentucky and I'm finishing
my PhD in molecular biology and to go
through debt-free I did a lot of
scholarships did a lot of work oh man
hard work a lot of hard working I had
dogs at one point you wait wait you
working three jobs yeah you're still
alive still alive there we go barely go
hey man yes sir I live in southeastern
Ohio
I graduated with a bachelor's degree
from Franklin University and
cybersecurity and I paid for college by
living at home and working hard and
unfortunately didn't apply for many
scholarships that's one thing I would
change but yeah working hard through
school would you stay at home with your
mom and dad you still alive - that's
good
yes ma'am
my name is Annabel bender I'm Jordans
wife and I turned down my dream school
to stay at home and go to school which
is something I said I would never do and
I pay for school by working two or three
part-time jobs until my senior year when
it was almost completely covered by
scholarships did you meet him when he
was in with his mom - yes but we didn't
know each other when we were going
through school so it was the summer
before her senior year that we found
each other in among a lot of things the
debt-free work ethic stood out to us
stood out okay so that's good you're
giving guys hope right now who are still
at home
yes ma'am my name is Dejah decent I live
in Durham North Carolina I went to
school at Purdue University for
undergrad and my graduate degree is from
University of Maryland my undergrad
degree was paid for through a full-ride
scholarship and graduate school was paid
for through my company I loved it we
just talked to you in a radio I think
Wednesday and me and Dave was like you
have to be here and you can yes yes yeah
you need yeah Joe talk to us man I'm
from Charlottesville Virginia I
graduated from the University of
Kentucky with a degree in exercise
physiology my story's a little bit
different than these guys
my mom and my aunt Rita worked extremely
hard to be able to put myself and my two
siblings through school debt-free Wow
wow that's wow that's different from the
others your mom and your aunt did what
they needed to do they did they did
that's good can we clap for them y'all
yes
all right so let's let's go ahead and
talk with this young lady right here she
just flew by that she got a half a
million dollars in scholarships people
are saying it's impossible so Christine
I got just two quick questions for you
because I really want to know I want
America to know that you did it if you
can do it they can do it what was the
role of your mom and what was the secret
to getting all of this money like did
you spend all of it
not all of it but basically the first
day of my freshman year of high school
my mom sat me down and she said
Christina I love you and I believe in
you but there's just no way that I can
support you financially once you
graduate from high school so you've got
to figure out your own way to pay for
college and at first I was shocked I
thought why are you telling me this I'm
a freshman in high school what can I do
about it but at the same time I knew
that she was just trying to help my
family could not afford college my dad
passed away after a long and painful
battle with brain cancer so she was a
single mom and she knew that if she gave
me that information early on then
perhaps I could work hard and apply for
scholarships and win so it was amazing
she sat down with me and we started
researching
everything we could find out about the
process we read every book we could get
our hands on we read interviews we
reached out to alumni and my high school
to try to figure out you know what do
you do to be successful in the
scholarship application process and then
we created a strategy and I worked
really hard throughout high school to
build up my resume and to build a really
strong scholarship application and then
senior year of high school I just
treated it like a part-time job I
applied applied applied we would spend
so many hours in the library at night
just talking through the different essay
is going over them a hundred times and
then thankfully all of the hard work
paid off and that's how I won a half a
million dollars in scholarships hard
work dedication and going at it like
it's your job
totally definitely I mean it's worth it
if you spend that time in high school if
you spend two hours applying for a
scholarship that allows you to win a
thousand dollars that's like making five
hundred bucks whatever that's more money
than you're gonna make in any other
part-time job in high
welcome all right you might as well what
I get tired of hearing people say I
can't do it I can't I don't have the
time to look up scholarships I had one
pair of parenting that's overwhelming
I'm like well your child spends six
hours on social media they can spend a
couple of hours looking up scholarships
and you did it and you got all this
money and your mom thank you because
your mom did something that parents are
scared to do they went have the
conversation with you and said hey I
can't do it it's all on you and when it
became all on you you went through it
now Lauren your situation is I love it
okay so you're six months I'm getting
you're six months away from getting your
PhD correct eight months from getting
your ph.d debt-free free okay I love it
but the secret to your success was you
started in Community College yeah part
of it a lot of it was dedication to
scholarships as well but yeah Community
College made a huge roll the first of
all I picked my major based off of
classes that I took there I loved my
teacher was really passionate and that
lit a fire in me for for science and the
the relationships that I built there I
still utilize today like just the other
day one of my teachers from my very
first anatomy and physiology class wrote
me a letter of recommendation for a
fellowship and I took her class ten
years ago ten years ago so the community
college has played a huge part in my
education so I want you to encourage the
people watching this right now who are
thinking you know what I got to go to
Community College but that doesn't mean
I'm smart it means that I failed what
would you say to them watching right now
I mean you're about to be I mean you
gonna have your PhD and no one's gonna
ask you where did you start it
they're just gonna be like you're a you
you are at the Bob so what would you say
to people right now who may have to
start off and who will start off at
Community College right now yeah I guess
I didn't have the
little status symbol and other seems to
be like a lot of status around where you
went to school I knew that that was
where I could afford and I got a lot of
pushback there was one woman in
particular she asked where I was going
to school and I told her the Community
College and she said I would rather my
kid not go to school then go through the
shame of going to a community that's why
she's in debt right now I don't know but
I would say definitely don't let people
like that tear you down you know I'm
sitting here today debt-free at the end
of the PhD her opinion is irrelevant
yeah yeah people's opinion is irrelevant
I love that we here Dave in the
background laughing so now to the couple
you know to Mister mrs. bender this is
funny you're living at home in your
mom's basement going to school you find
an amazing wife she did you look past
that you have a lucky one cuz the
average woman just ain't gonna happy but
she let now you live in your mama's
basement you can't can't do this but so
your secret was living at home work hard
you skipped your dream school like you
skipped your dream school to go to
education what would you dream school
under I'm curious it was a private
university a private Christian
University but I had that school picked
out since I was in junior high school
what Junior High I knew I wouldn't I was
gonna go here I was gonna major in this
oh you know it all oh I knew everything
and two weeks before move-in day I had
my classes I had a roommate I had
everything and I called my admissions
counselor and I said take me off the
list I can't pay for this and right did
the one thing that I said I would never
do which is live at home and go to
square we rely you're two weeks away
you're already in your classes you are
already in your dream school you already
had it and you let it go because you
decided you couldn't pay for it I did
basic math and a basic math told you
that you just you can't do it yeah and
it wasn't worth it
and I it was a pride
I could have gotten two four years of
school at a branch of a state school and
I didn't apply for that school and then
that's the schooling that going to and
it had to pay for this you had to pay
for those two years of college because I
couldn't have spoiled my pride before
hey Jordan gimme gimme some love bruh
your wife needs to teach the other wives
basic math so talk to us about yours as
well what made you stay home cuz you
know the typical young person wants to
go off to college go to the dorms enjoy
the fraternity parties and have a good
time get away from home like myself and
just have a good time what made you stay
home and really do it the way that you
did it yeah well my parents always
impressed on us kids that debt is to be
avoided at all costs and so I never
considered student loans as an option I
applied for FAFSA and didn't get grants
and saw all loans as an option but I
never considered that i-i've always
worked so I had the ability to pay for
it to myself and my parents and I mean I
was blessed to be able to live
technically I lived on the middle floor
I was in the basement
[Laughter]
he's a little bit high know some people
think working throughout college is not
it's not smart because you should be
able to focus on your college but
studies are showing that if you work in
10 to 19 hours a week you actually come
out with a better GPA than people who do
not work was it difficult working for
both of you or why are you were in
school well I think for me I mean
graduating and getting a job employers
look for experience almost more so in my
field than a degree so working through
college gives you you're getting the
education and you're getting experience
on top of that I mean it makes you have
to make sacrifices with like your social
life and and it's it's a lot of work it
is a ton of work but it's it's
definitely worth it because of the
experience and because of you don't debt
I love I love I love it and we both
graduated summa [ __ ] laude from our
degrees with our degrees and Jordan
double majored in IT and cybersecurity
while working full time and I
have gone to Russia Uganda and Southeast
Asia throughout school in the four years
of college and we're alive so I think it
worked out yo so I go over to JJ I just
met you and we're on the phone me you
and Dave talking to 16 million people
and you call in and you're like no I
also skipped my dream school and I just
worked hard and I'll give us a little
bit about your story like what what
happened I know your mom played a role
she had a conversation but what made you
want to skip the dream school and go to
write at you went so it boils down to
the financial aid packages like it was
Purdue versus a private Technical
College in Chicago and Purdue was a
full-ride in that private school was
like $40,000 a year and so I'm like do I
go somewhere for free or do I go to my
dream school get student loans and pay
$40,000 a year no I chose to go to
Purdue anybody that knew me at the time
knew that I didn't want to go there but
I also did not want student loans under
any circumstances Oh everybody you did
not want to go to produce I did not want
to go but you made a choice to go there
it's for so you can avoid student loans
and graduate debt-free yes
sacrifice you're weird thank you and so
you're there but not only did you did
your bachelor's that way you got your
masters that way as well yes so I
started working when I got out of school
for undergrad and I was like I have so
much free time on my hands what should I
do with myself I was like let me go back
to school and my company at the time
offered tuition reimbursement 100% so I
decided to go back to school and they
pay for it man I love it I love it
Joel you are the different one on stage
that I pray that one day I could be like
your mom and like your hunt talked a
little bit about that I mean you grew up
I mean you don't even have credit cards
like you are just really focused because
of how your
and aunt thought you went to Kentucky I
did I did I went to Kentucky
my mom there's three of us my mom worked
full-time and put herself through
Community College and ended up with a
nursing degree
my aunt waited tables all through
college ended up with a PhD in
mechanical engineering started her own
business sold it and you know with that
and the help of my mom they were able to
pay my way through school and I'll be
honest with you guys I didn't appreciate
it when I had it to be completely honest
I didn't appreciate this until the day
that I walked across the stage and I
graduated and I knew I was gonna pay $0
in debt and every one of my friends had
student loans to be where I was and so
now I'm in a position where I'm married
my wife and I have a two month old baby
and the first thing I wanted to do when
he popped out was taking Social Security
card open up a 529 this thing rolling
because I understand how important it is
ten still those values and my son and my
mom and my aunt have really blessed me
and setting me up to be able to work
extremely hard to one day do the same
thing for my son yeah yeah yeah now I
love your story but then your wife story
is completely opposite yeah of yours
yeah she also graduated debt-free give
us a basis of how does she do it yeah so
she debt-free as well her route was
different than mine she didn't come from
a lot of money at all
so what she would do is go through fast
foot apply for grants and whatever the
difference was she had to pay the
minimum amount to be able to keep her
classes so after that amount was paid
then she would pay a minimum monthly
balance towards the rest of that amount
and then at the end of our semester paid
the rest of it off so see she did that
through her undergrad
and then also her master's program as
well so through grants and then also
saving a lot of money working getting
help through family she was able to pay
her way through through college I love
it I love it we have a future PhD
master's degree this guys traveling
around the world training NFL players
and training good-looking people like
myself so we we see on this panel that
it is possible and there's no excuse in
30 seconds I want each one of you all to
give someone watching right now words of
encouragement to avoid student loans and
what should they be doing now to impact
their future just be strategic about the
process look into your options there are
so many out there if you're willing to
work hard and put your full self into it
so get on Google go to your library read
every book you can find read this
wonderful book that's coming out tonight
and just become knowledgeable and go for
it I mean we are all living proof that
it is possible we have completely
different backgrounds we just were all
willing to work hard and really go for
it so I just encourage you to go for it
as well I would say don't be afraid of a
few really hard years cuz it's
definitely gonna pay off and don't give
up let's say tenacity is key Wow I love
it yes sir yeah don't be afraid to go to
Community College to save money and what
apply for scholarships that's one thing
that I didn't do much but I mean like
you guys were saying before there's a
bunch that just go unused every year so
there's people who aren't applying so it
just appliance it's free money for
college work you can do it work and if
you're a parent the comparison of the
golden ticket of college that you're a
bad parent if you do not send your kid
to college is so wrong my parents are
amazing and I owe them so much of my
life and Jordans parents are amazing and
they kind of pay for our college but
they installed work ethic and
responsibility and generosity in us so
do your kids a favor and make them work
they're gonna be
better people wore it and apply to
multiple colleges and do the math sit
down and do the math and look at your
options ask yourself what you want and
then work hard
basic math yes ma'am students take
advantage of Honor classes AP classes
dual credit classes because those
classes can transfer over to college and
that shortens your time while you're in
school and that shortens the amount of
money you have to pay while you're there
so take advantage of those classes early
some schools offer them as early as
sophomore year so just look into that
and make sure you take advantage joe
cool what I want to say may be a little
off the wall so Anthony I apologize in
advance but I just want to talk to the
people
honestly that look like me and Asia and
are making excuses hmm stop doing that
we live in America we live in a free
country we you know we play that cars
that weirdo right not everybody starts
out in the same place but we're all
running the same race it's gonna look a
little different just because you feel
like somebody else is in a different
position than you are and they're more
successful than you are it really
doesn't matter because that's their race
you need to run yours we have the same
opportunities out there to make it I'm
sitting here they just sitting here and
no disrespect to all these other people
up here as well cuz they worked hard as
well I'm the only one sitting up here
telling you guys that my momma my aunt
paid my way these guys are sitting here
telling you that they actually worked
and got those scholarships so it is it
is possible to get this done Wow
Wow
there's not much for me to say after
that you know there's no excuses just
work do the math and run your race you
know we have this brand-new book coming
out debt-free degree I wrote it I'm so
grateful about it but man we have an
amazing team here that is also behind
this whole movement that we're trying to
do and we put together this great book
trailer to really help you understand
what we're about and what this book is
about someone go to that right now thank
you so much it was my junior year in
high school and I was that kid that was
freaking out because I was scared
an admissions counselor came from a
local college there and said hey if you
do not have a plan or how are you gonna
pay for college right now you are ahead
I was terrified because I didn't have a
plan in my parents didn't have a plan
and I remember taking out student loans
to not just fund college but also to
fund my lifestyle and that was the
biggest mistake that I made and I am on
a mission to help your kids to help all
students a boy making that decision
my name is Anthony O'Neill and I travel
across the country talking to thousands
of students every single day how to
start a good solid foundation for your
life do you know that the average
student will graduate about thirty five
thousand dollars in student loan debt
this is ridiculous
I wrote a brand new book called
debt-free degree where I'm teaching
parents to step-by-step process on how
to get your kids into college in brew
college 100% debt-free not only am i
talking about scholarships lands for
classroom even be taking but I'm also
teaching on what secrets behind prepare
for the a CT and the SAT how you get
those scores up and what are some
different ways like Community College
trade schools what are the secrets are
all in my brand new book debt-free
degree go to Anthony Neal comm or Dave
Ramsey calm and order your copy today
[Music]
alright alright welcome back to
debt-free degree Town Hall love watching
that trailer that gets me pumped you
know what else gets me pumped watching
those kids up there that instilled a lot
of confidence in me for the future of
America weren't those some incredible
incredible young people we are back with
your questions we're gonna take some
from the audience here in-house as well
as social media and I want to start with
someone right here in the crowd you come
on up sir
tell us your name my name is Shawn and
your question for Dave and Anthony first
of all thank you for hosting this event
and it's encouraging to hear you guys so
community college it's heard a lot about
community colleges sometimes a stigma a
lot of times a stigma is that they are
less than or it's for the kids that
didn't get into a real college how do we
break that cuz they're a lot more
affordable they are a lot more
affordable and I think what we got to
just start hyping up these community
colleges and stop saying as a culture
that community colleges are horrible you
just heard that young lady on the stage
saying Community College is the thing
that really started her career she got
encouragement from her professors and so
community colleges to me is honestly not
a dumb move it's a smartest move because
it lets me know you're thinking about
the basic math and so we can start
showing young people that hey going to
Harvard going to Yale compared to start
off at a community college is this good
thing we know we need this flip it
around go to Community College state of
Tennessee you go there for the first two
years for free like free that's easy
math this is so if we can start hyping
community colleges up and really
starting couraging our young people to
go there and then we'll see a big
difference in young people going to
Community College there are two kinds of
college professors great and sucks
and there's two kinds of community
colleges there's some want some that are
substandard and so you've got to your
research you don't want to go in and get
a substandard education because then
when you do move up the next two years
you won't be able to cut it because you
want one of laid a solid foundation so
that there's a reason to have that
reputation is because some of them for
years have not done well they don't do a
good job and so we're not saying carte
blanche always go there but you can't
say that about a state school and you
can't say that about an Ivy League
school that a hundred percent of the
time you can't say that about some of
these private high schools that some
people spend twenty and thirty and forty
thousand dollars a year to send their
kid to but it's always substantially
better the acct scores may not even be
higher than that high school and so you
can't just can't take you know baby
bathwater thing you can't take
generalizations but so do your research
go on there walk around you know feel
the air you can tell what's going on see
if the professors have anybody home you
know I've met professors there's not
anybody home and not even by coming up
the driveway you know I mean there's
just dumber no rock but tenure got him a
job and kept it and so but other times
we've had professors that in life
changers for some of my professors from
University of Tennessee you're still
personal friends to this day just like
she was saying and so you know you just
got to do your research on that but the
interesting thing is this you think
about this you go get your taxes done
you walk in the guys with CPA the gals
with CPA how many time you ask them more
than one school that's good zero you got
you you know you go in to your doctor
how many you know how many of you know
where your doctor graduate from college
does MD none of you you know I had an
architect draw this building I'd only I
did where the guy went to school dad
young building standing up though so
we'll check that stuff out that's the
biggest lie we have ever believed that
where you went to school has some
correlation with your future success it
has almost zero correlation with your
future success where you went to school
so long as it was adequate education
meaning that you got the tools in your
belt because it's not the degree that
matters it's the knowledge knowledge is
what gives you power the degree is a
joke and we all know it's a joke you can
wave it around people look at it I had
one guy working here come in he goes I
got like four degrees Davie some people
like me working for a fortune 500 we
make a lot more than then you're paying
me here
and I said well you're working for a
small business son you're raised here is
effective when you are and so I think
you do with your dad blame degree can
you kill it and drag it home and that's
how you get paid in the real world so go
learn those kinds of skills and put
those with basic knowledge and you'll be
fine where you graduated from one half
of one percent of the jobs in America
give a rip yep the rest of them
it's a laughing stock I guarantee you I
got nine hundred team members here you
know I mean we've heard because of where
they went to school
zero zero can date dude job that's the
whole thing man that's a and I don't
care where you went to school I don't
care if you went to school for that
matter can you do the job the school is
an indication you have the knowledge
tools and your belt to execute that's
the thing yes sir all right Thank You
Shawn for that great question we're
gonna take one from social media here
this one comes in from a Nuri what do I
do if the degree I want to pursue is
that an out-of-state college what do I
do if the degree I want to pursue is
that an out-of-state college I would ask
is that the only college that offers
this particularly agree for real you
know me just I've never heard of a
pretty specialized degree if special
real special it's a whack degree in mind
if that's the only one but again it goes
back to what Dave and I are talking
about all night do the research I would
say it sounds like you may want to go to
that school that's your dream school but
if you're saying you want to get this
particular degree do the research I can
almost guarantee that that degree is
offered somewhere with inside of your
state but you got to do the research
that's a simple place it may or may not
be and but you know again that's usually
is the biggest lie out there there are
very few degrees feels if the degree is
that much of a niche is there a job
market for it right I mean not many
people hiring people for left handed
puppetry so I mean Germa poke in history
ain't a big ain't a big demand for it
right now so you just you know if it's
that specialized that nuanced is the job
market that nuance yeah that's what
would scare me and so I doubt it I don't
believe it but you could prove me wrong
I'd be open to that
prove me wrong we're gonna move to a
question from our audience come on up
you know lady what's your name
Victoria Torino Victoria where you're
from Nashville here right so what is
your question for Anthony and Dave so
first off thank you guys so much for
hosting this event and um it's an honor
to ask y'all this question so my
question is I'm very interested in the
medical field and I hear all the time
that going to medical school debt-free
is impossible so what is the answer to
that question I don't believe nothing is
impossible okay that's a big that's
gonna be my straightforward answer I
believe that if you really sit down
write division and do the research and
write the plan down and step back and
you have to tell yourself hey I'm gonna
have to actually cashflow this thing
there are still scholarships available
you can still actually get connected
with different particular firms around
it even help you go to school maybe go
to a particular Hospital and offer to
work with them and they'll even help pay
for your school but a key thing is you
got to determine in your mind you're
gonna take debt off of the table you're
gonna do the proper research and while
you're researching what is the best and
affordable school what scholarship
opportunities are available do they have
any programs available that I can get
into recently I met a doctor and she
actually went to a particular state and
that state actually helped her pay for
her school because they needed more
doctors in that state so it's all about
- stepping back not rushing not jumping
into it but doing the research and the
key thing is just take that off the
table when you take that off the table
you'll start seeing an option to start
popping up and you may have to go a
little bit slower and work a lot harder
up front or your school are you senior
in high school what's your GPA
I think it's 3.9 3.9 good okay okay roba
here's a good shot it's very hard to do
what you're asking today it's not as
easy what we've been discussing
tonight's getting a 4-year degree in
marketing and you can do that that free
if you can't do that after tonight we
presented the evidence just shut up I
mean really
okay but what you're talking about doing
is very very hard to do it is possible
to do it
the primary way I've seen it done over
the years is called the MD ph.d program
and there are about 10 universities in
the u.s. that have medical programs that
have the MD ph.d program the essence of
the program it's almost like a
fellowship that's why I ask about your
GPA it's tough to get in very but if you
can get in you become an employee of the
University and they give you free
tuition and that's what it amounts to
you're working on your MD while you're
helping them with their PhD programs you
basically become a proctor and some
other things you're gonna be teaching
some classes some other things while
you're there at the in your post-grad
stuff and so that's what you're looking
for if you can get into an MD ph.d
program I just I know a guy just
graduate from Duke on that the other day
one of my friends kids went through it
and I got a complete free ride $0 he's
an MD it's a big deal very difficult to
do there's not many of them and not many
people go through it it's not like
thousands and thousands like these
scholarships is about can be done second
thing is talk to some of the hospital
companies like here in Nashville we've
got HCA which is one of the largest
hospital companies in the world and
there is a docked shortage because
healthcare if you hadn't noticed is
jacked up okay there's a doc shortage
and there's a nurse shortage and some of
those guys are entertaining things
they've never done before which is a
scholarship program you are then
obligated to work for them for a few
years when you come out they will pay
you for that but it's almost like an
indentured servant kind of thing you're
like doing the military when you can go
in the military they'll pay for it
they'll pay for you to become a doctor
but you're gonna be a doctor in the
military for a while to give them the
payback on that so you can work that
through that's another option as well
the last one and this one's even more
rare but I'm just gonna throw it out
there just for the fun of it some of the
wealthiest companies in America today
are the drug companies guess who sells
their drugs for them the doctors and
guess who they like to have as friends
doctor doctors and so the scholarship
programs coming out of those towards the
medical schools are real and just I
guess the last piece of advice and it
does come in with everything else we've
been saying is med school is probably
the most ridiculous of all the degrees
in the spectrum of what you pay to
become an MD you pay to become an MD
over here
150 grand over here 650 grand same exact
MD you know maybe some specializations
maybe some surgical things you're trying
to get it on that kind of thing but what
you know if you just want to be a
medical doctor you wanted to be an MD
you know just because you got accepted
at that one you know I finally got in
one and it's it's four hundred thousand
and I can't do it well that just keep
going you got to find another one you
got to find another one you got to get
accepted on another one but everybody so
desperate just to get accepted then once
they get accepted they take that as a
sign from God that they're supposed to
go a half million dollars in debt and so
watch what you're paying for the school
all of you for anything but this is when
it really becomes dramatic because of
the numbers very difficult task I'm not
saying what you're doing is not uphill
but it can be done thank you yes three
point nine can we clap for her y'all Hey
thank you all for those great questions
both in person and on social media now
if you're watching tonight you may be
inspired from the stories you've heard
the information you've heard but you may
be thinking what do I do now how do I
put these principles in to practice so
Dave help us out what can these people
watching do to move forward in their
lives with this well I think I've said
about 10 times tonight but I'm firmly
convinced that you know there's
scholarships there's work
there's living at home there's all those
things but when you run the math out on
all the different things the difference
in the $10,000 tuition for an in-state
college for your undergrad and a 40 or
50 or $60,000 tuition that's the big
piece of math yeah so if you don't have
the cash to go to school and you're
looking at that the biggest mathematical
change in the equation is college choice
choose to go to the cheaper school where
you can afford it's that simple that's
the biggest thing
you can't work enough while you're in
school to offset the difference in ten
thousand and fifty thousand a year
that's the difference in forty thousand
and two hundred thousand over four years
yeah I mean that's the best pretty sweet
dadgum college job if you can make up
that difference but you can make enough
to cover that ten thousand dollars a
year is the average in
state tuition that's 833 dollars a month
the typical person calling me on they're
getting out of debt delivering pizzas
four nights a week making fifteen
hundred bucks a month so fifteen hundred
bucks a month will pay 833 a month why
is it you can't do this cuz you don't
work yeah like she said do you like her
work her advice I like this not her work
her first one was basic math basic math
followed by work I like it I like it too
like it's tough and I'm excited Dave
because the number one key thing like
you said is making sure that you choose
affordable college and I just got to
keep saying it's just do the research
there are so many programs out there
that are offering free or reduced
tuition if they just take the step step
back and just actually do the research
yeah just father you know the whole
thing with Ramsey solutions everything
we do is all about meeting people where
they are cuz I've done a lot of stupid
stuff we've made fun of your stereo
earlier I mean we've all all done stupid
we didn't talk about your stupid stuff
there's a whole nother seminar it takes
a long time to set up my stupid stuff
it's a lengthy thing I got a PhD in to
UM be talked up my degree but uh you
know we've all done that the problem is
we have a culture wide set of stupid
going on with the subject right now and
the you know we joke about it we're I'm
sarcastic that's my style of humor and I
poke at people not jab them to get them
to think the truth is there's a lot of
people hurting yeah now hurting bad
right now because of this subject
suicides and depression and people
giving up their their dreams yeah and
they're not getting married because I
feel like they're overwhelmed they're
putting off having kids all because of
this subject and all that is it means
people are hurting and the only answer
to two people that are hurting is a new
way of looking at things if you continue
to do the same thing over and over again
and you expect a different result that's
called the definition of
sanity in America we gotta stop this
it's completely out of control
and Anthony's giving you the tools this
book comes out on this coming a week
from today it hits the street so you can
buy it for one more week at $19 we're
throwing in $40 worth of stuff the
e-book a bunch of I was gonna say DVDs
we don't do those anymore about videos
will be delivered to your computer
selling you aids if that's right save me
money I'm just giving it Sarah now but
we're gonna give you some air and it's
gonna have a video attached to it and
put it in your computer and you'll be
able to watch Anthony do his thing and
dr. Megan Meeker at their smart
parenting event which is absolutely
incredible those are all add-ons for
this book so you get a bargain if you
buy it between now and and next weekend
theny will be on the road next week and
be in New York starting next next Monday
doing media and all over America you'll
see them out there America and your
areas come by his book signing and see
him
we're also have mentioned this launch
today this podcasters podcast incredible
man borrow it future as you all can see
where I hear it it is amazing leave
interview some of the top leading
millionaires billionaires financial
experts college experts and we really
share the story of how serious it is
Dave but we also bring the solution to
how do we fix it and I'm so excited
you're on the road next week I traveled
around the world to talk about the book
but really just to talk about how do we
end this to the loan crisis yeah and and
it's not just the book we have the
borrower future podcast but then also
today we're launching my several
resources on my website some really cool
tools I mean the grill the scholarship
search we mentioned that earlier 10,000
scholarships on there it's completely
free yes the college checklist is on
there's completely free of the college
calculator you enter your college you're
considering and it will automatically
start calculating for you what it's
going to cost and we've got all the
major colleges and most of the minor
ones in the database and so all you
gotta do is just put in the name of it
he'll start doing it for you so it's all
completely free we want to do this for
you we're gonna change this thing man we
aren't changing Dave today we're
starting something that we're going to
be doing forever moving forward we're
giving away an offering ten
thousand dollars and scholarships on my
website so we're giving away a $5,000
scholarship into $2,500 scholarships
it's gonna run throughout the entire
month of October and I'm really excited
about that because that's connected to
the scholarship search tool you're on
the hair I'm traveling around the world
that's the number one thing young people
are asking me where do I go to look for
scholarships go to my website apply for
our scholarship today and then also all
right there's no purchase necessary you
don't have to fill out an essay if
you're breathing you're in the running
baby that's it
high school students over there -
Anthony Oney we're gonna get away ten
thousand bucks
ten thousand forty cool speedy prep has
jumped in beside us here and helped us
with that sponsoring it appreciate those
guys but so we're giving away free money
for scholarships
we got scholarship search tools and
college calculator tools we got a
debt-free degree book to walk you
through the process we've got the
podcast it's eight episodes now coming
out borrowed future it is all its game
oh hey it's time to cause a ruckus yes
this has gotten out of hand
and this guy right here he's got to do
it I'm so proud of you thank you Dave
thank you so much
so America we know that right now
there's one point six trillion dollars
in student loan debt they're estimating
by the end of this year we'll be at one
point seven currently 11 million student
loan borrowers are in default by the end
of this year we'll have another million
if we do the math that is every 28
seconds somebody is going in into
default with their student loans our
young people are graduating college with
student loan debt and they can't start
their dream careers they can't even
start a family they're not having kids
the average person is gonna graduate and
12 years later we'll have 65% 65% of
their original loan balance still left
but then people of minorities they will
have about 113 percent I'm sick and
tired of where we are and I have to do
something so my team and I are Dave and
I we wrote the book debt-free degree
they step-by-step process on how we all
can change this completely my kids will
not go to college and graduate in debt
and be in their sixties and seventies
paying back student loans they're gonna
go to college 100% debt-free they're
gonna graduate and help the economy
they're gonna start businesses they're
gonna start taking control of their
future they're gonna build wealth and
legacies and your kids can do it too you
can do it too and tonight it starts
right here in the great city of
Nashville Tennessee and Ramsey Solutions
headquarters and this is a big movement
and I want you to be a part of it join
me go to my website Anthony oh calm use
all the resources share this video
because we're going to shake the country
in a Congress and America will have to
answer to us when it comes to the
student loans
y'all I'm excited I'm pumped I'm ready
to hit the road again thank you all so
much for joining us tonight
well it's been an incredible night I
want to thank you all for tuning in as
we answered your questions and laid out
a plan to going to college debt-free and
make sure to check out Anthony O'Neill
comm for all of the resources mentioned
tonight and you can help us spread the
word like Anthony mentioned by sharing
this video with your friends sharing the
resources that we'll mention tonight in
using the hashtag debt-free degree all
over social media let's cause a movement
people and with that it's been my
pleasure to be your host thank you so
much for joining us
[Applause]
[Applause]
and this is cool the book doesn't
release for another week but we have
physical copies that you can get tonight
this is the only place in America to
grab that book